good morning Red Dead online beta howdy
partners thank you guys for being
patient thank you for hanging in there
just trying to fire all of our brain
cells at once doesn't go well sometimes
that's Rob handler I'm Mike McCarty I 7
am here yeah well cool it's it's live a
couple of us have been playing it let me
cut to that feed Eric okay our live tech
producer here oh look at you going back
and forth between story and online
mm-hmm super super food should show up
if you if you have the Ultimate Edition
this should be live for you right now
crap I accidentally loaded story so you
can't see my feet and I start you you go
for it I'll catch up so we're going to
start a character look at all this nice
policies be a good boy
so yeah we have two feets here I think I
should be able to cut to mine
look at that we'll go back and forth
this is gonna be real fun so you could
play a single player and I'll play
multiplayer no yeah I think you guys for
joining us we're gonna fire up see what
this online is all about so if you have
the ultimate edition you're able to play
today
and then throughout the week up until
Friday if you own the game front by
Friday you'll be able to play but I
think every day is like tomorrow if you
play it on launch day you'll be able to
play tomorrow more right and then if you
played between then and the 29th you'll
be able to play Wednesday Thursday and
then yeah something like that pretty
much if you play it at all you'll be
able to play I think it's live for
everybody by Friday the beta I don't
know like one
[Music]
let's see what we got Oh character
creator cool I think you look pretty
good assets
yeah that looks like oh man woman do you
have a preference what are you gonna do
I'm gonna do guy okay I'm a woman I
think so yeah I know Ben is out there
Lucy's out there playing we're gonna
we're gonna meet up with them and see if
we get a posse going look at you dang I
look thick like straggled like Gavin in
the chat was anyone seen Gavin
appearance I won't take crazy listen
online very similar to GTA online go
figure
yeah you like those blemishes and
everything younger uh I don't know man
30 I'm 31 30 years young 30 years young
crazy cat lady says Brinsley named her
Gavin it says hydroid okay I can that's
right we are playing on ps4 Perot
can't change the hair huh I see not yet
smoocher is one of the looks to lift
options like valley
which rupee small errors I have tiny
ears quite a record will have on you
whoa-ohh
floss much you don't you can make your
kisser however you want
we're called you could do dirty already
here oh look I said on my feet it
started off with like a different
generic I don't know what type they want
me to do with my I can't look with the
chompers oh that's like missus what's
the Oh what is her name
I have a once a half fusion grit suits
Kershaw Greenshaw yeah that's good
enough we'll get into it lifestyle oh I
don't
yeah well sick my whistle
that's good that's a good whistle Oh
like two of two points left to a sign
yep health stamina I kind of like
stamina and Deadeye there we go here we
go
yeah oh she looks good there she's
photogenic
that's like Will Ferrell him I don't
know what to do with my hands
well who goes that tela diggin I do yeah
yeah yeah it's a clue what to do with my
hands
Wow yeah the skin color can be changed
there was three there were three options
I believe oh here we go
Oh some months later some months later
so this is like a prequel to a prequel
right it's a pretty yes they're going
backwards wait a sec oh we're never mind
damn it okay this is in the game I mean
obviously but okay all right you might
remember this if you've played a lot of
the game how's the baton kitchens a
staff
[Music]
what are you standing there for
doll giggles you you you with the hammer
and you you'll do we need to perform a
work detail out in Valentine come on get
in
open the gate Hatchin escape
[Music]
leaving syska Jonah Valentine it's a
decent travel I tell you what old
Jameson is a wretched sour old bastard
in no mistake you not stay calm and
there weren't saying nothing we are now
shut up you know my wife has acquired
ideas significantly above her station
she's been reading too many goddamn book
personally I'm against education women I
mean man man I guess unnecessary doesn't
add much to the world education
this guy's a character already good day
gentlemen oh don't do anything stupid
nobody gets shot act like fools and the
pair of you will be dead within a minute
now what are your names Jenkins and
Milliken
well mr. Jenkins and mr. Milliken throw
your guns to the ground to get on down
here that's it very glad to meet you
it's not worth being rash you boys get
paid to Saturday you get that salary
whether these people escape or not your
wives presumably wants you alive let him
out now please okay okay
you all run away aside from you try to
stay out of trouble this is a stroke of
good fortune for all of you use it hey
why can't I run yeah mr. Jenkins and mr.
Milich you be so kind as to quickly run
away before somebody gets shot entirely
unnecessarily go on don't look back mr.
wind I believe he was $50 we agreed on
it was here's fifty each each yes now
get out of here both of you my employer
and I appreciate your professionalism
all we did was stand there and look
tough and you did it fantastically well
good day gentlemen
now ma'am how about you pick up these
guns and we move out so mistress is
waiting for us
[Music]
down down down down you look like a
stone-cold killer howdy partner howdy
partner someone said that's the offer
that's what that's the officer we save
from this story that's know I don't know
I actually was not really paying
attention because I'm now finally
sitting up my character thank you guys
for joining us for playing Red Dead
online beta you're currently I guess got
busted out of jail mossad jail what up
there do wells what else happened with
some other highlights I was a statistic
a prison which if you played the game
it's on the far east side on an island
off the coast if you played a lot of the
game then you might recognize it we
won't get into that but um this is Gavin
she is 30 she that's all we know about
her so far yeah so we're all we got a
few people oh here we go we have a few
people in the office playing as well
Lucy and Ben and Jake when he gets in
will be playing got a few wet pounds so
here's a question cuz I saw as I was
making my character in just a little
weird shell here I'm just going through
it right now
but how does Dead Eye work I don't know
that was yeah I was wondering cuz I
thought when I put a point into yeah oh
you did okay guy Vina
says someone got a horse got my prison
overalls on still not overalls onesie
sousou's I don't know it was suicide
suicide
Jesus says she looks 50 yeah I went with
the early gray so horley is the dude who
rescued me $400 don't know what my
significance is yet or why I was at said
sheriff's office I'm also not sure what
sheriff's office that was
why do I not hear oh I hear your game
audio right now oh no oh I think it's a
bug is it a bug no I hear your audio no
no you should I think you got a bug cuz
you we heard I've literally just heard
your guy I know I swept it but like I
think pushed pause yeah
you're not getting any audio hmm I don't
know I think it's a bug
you could you wanna switch to your feed
and maybe it's like my playstation or
something I think it's a bug man because
you because you can hear audio music
audio and the audio when you pause it I
don't think it's an E do it through ps4
working earlier I would I would maybe
keep playing and maybe we'll get to a
state I'll come back to you for now
there's some sort of dead eye but I
don't know how it's gonna work
yeah they literally blood me put a point
into a dead eye they're also like RPG
progression attributes here not sure how
they work completely yet yeah that's
weird because when I have music I have
pause menu and I can't yeah I hear what
the students saying you have subtitles
on there right
I had him on so if you were to talk no
he's looking at me talking mm-hmm we
going to hear quick I think you should
continue playing or we can cut to me I'm
in well I'm in a different area I'm in
the desert I'll cut to me for now yeah
do that
see if you can hear yours maybe yeah you
can hear yours yeah I really don't think
thanks where am i right now I must be an
owner armadillo yeah I am your Valentine
oh no I'm here yeah yeah you have a bug
you could you could try restarting if
you wanted I don't know why we're so
sure it's like I'm how do you like this
is
[Music]
breaking all those Ben is in the chat
saying he's getting disconnected a lot
eat remind just to be check I still hear
yeah oh you said hit your horse wait go
back
yeah he just said hitch my horn no no
you're talking to me that's a really
weird okay see if you can get to a safe
State okay
and then like food the game again okay
Jesse Adler we're back hello
yeah six years the clerk how do you do
what did you tell them yeah I have
subtitles on nothing
as we discussed Thank You Holly I do
hope we haven't inconvenienced you
dreadfully sure you don't object too
strongly
I know you're innocent well perhaps
exactly innocent but not guilty of what
you were accused I know you and those
who are with you that dad a little more
than Patsy's and that you were set up by
one of three men or a woman possibly
about all of them I can't be sure that
is all I know so far and one of these
people also made mrs. Leclerc a widow
and I will avenge my husband's death so
help me God
but I will not avenge it upon them who
did not cause it or caused it
unwittingly all these spaces are so
bizarre
holy please show our guests to their
tent and give them some fresh clothes to
put on refreshment
Jesse Leclerc does that sound familiar
Lantern I believe do I want a hat
Hey hey what color you think I should
pick what stuff
[ __ ] as weird bata
I like that one
dan bandanna is not yet duster coat I'm
into that
that looks good girl oh no shirt that
looks better
oh that's a nice cowboy vest their
traditional vest let's do a do a green
hey that's what that is I did shirt
already there we go weapon equipment
okay can't do anything they're boots
no boots do that now it heard in the
sand all right oh I don't know any coach
it may be cool sure we're at the same
spot sweet that looks more comfortable
Harley here madam your very good health
I suppose it beats dying yeah you still
have that bug yeah he's taken years for
now I don't mind because you and your no
shirt with the duster that would look
good funny I should have done that into
the town at approximately the same time
my husband was shot in the back but by
another gun firing different bullets to
those you possessed when you were
arrested these bullets
this was their mistake you around it up
and sentenced to death all because you
came to town and didn't talk too much
and seemed like you were nasty anyway
here they are the people who run
Blackwater mr. Jeremiah Shaw banker real
estate speculator and crook Mr Amos
Lansing ranch Oh mr. Venus's don't ask
about his first name his wife anus
Lansing of the sport back then crook
enough for my best friend Teddy Brown
had disgraced brother outlaw wanted man
and still in contact with them all I ask
of you is your help in finding out quite
what happened this is the clerk would
like to help you get back on your feet
get back to work
whatever your work may be I don't judge
you want to rob rob you want to save
innocent folk do that as well
but you need me just as much as I need
you I think we all understand each other
I hope we do looks dead inside we're
gonna be outlaws a gang or what in the
West for greed greed when there's quite
enough for everybody I don't care what
your scruples ours to killing I will
take the full burden of that sin upon my
shoulders goodbye for now
then Hawley go introduce him to nice mr.
Krebbs mr. Krebbs you like groups sounds
sinister yeah long past his prime of
course but he hasn't gone entirely crazy
just yet and he will help you better
than most of his ilk Crips Harley this
is your new boss Oh pleased to meet you
partner
JB Crips at your service we'll pay to
get your camp established mrs. Leclerc
is a generous benefactor and where are
we headed
hmm oh you can okay okay
can't set a large camp quite yet I don't
have much of an option I guess looks
like I am consigned to just the
heartlands we're interesting so I got to
do gap to 13 different one Crips is
establishing your camp perhaps you can
go to the station and see the clerk then
head to see clay Davies he's a horse
thief and not a terribly nice one they
meet Crips back at your camp
see you shortly boss yeah maybe there's
an autosave so I can restart while
you're doing that yeah this looks like I
did not name it scrawny nag but I kind
of like that name
so dead-eyed currently doesn't work when
i try it
mr. cinematic mode still your head there
is this cool
they'll be dope riding with people yeah
cool
oh my second here you're gonna read yeah
I'm just gonna double check before I
reboot cool but yeah you got so you
started oh you started like down
Southwest
ride school Red Dead sure did
so I have on very the basics here I
guess
I wonder if I'm even in like ice I mean
I should be in a server I still know if
there's anyone around
Oh what's I know this place this is
where you see Irish for the first time
right yeah they looks really familiar
could you know that's where I go to mine
really quick just like briefly sure
let's see if I fixed it nope okay yeah
you're probably right
what about yours see yeah that's super
weird because I have I have audio but I
don't have it could be maybe it is I
don't know you try putting up the single
player and see what happens okay
all right well I restarted
oh there's emotes
you
I said go inside here oh it's uh yeah
it's that guy again you must be a horse
thief that's what he's talking about
he's one of us
he said you also were discouraged man
I'm Harry discouraged disappointed Alton
that's me anyway it's a pleasure to make
your acquaintance
I find your reticence charming real
charming by the way I heard you might
want to earn a little money man it's
some gentleman I've been robbing our
stages and they are not part of the club
if you catch my meaning
don't have anyway I'm sure they will
have something of interest to you too
ridge see what you can do okay
Aidan right there's anything by the way
mm a catalog only this issue just came
into this armpit of my land more
civilized and if all works out well my
colleagues and I move around these
stations as needed and all of us are
very discouraged we will all help a
fellow sufferer with pertinent
information
good afternoon sir it's so weird not
hearing the characters speak you know
yeah but it's just like on a GT online
yeah fact I mean it-it's it's it makes
sense I suppose all right let's
hopefully that worked
haha is that mine yeah oh wait go back
to yours I'll catch up and then we'll
meet up
okay sure I'm good yeah sounds good okay
yeah that was a bug I didn't change
anything and it was fine
interesting all right let's continue
this here then
so what remind me what you're doing
quest wise ah wanna meet up with someone
I believe so what nope nope see I'm in
the heartlands like more toward where
you start in the story you're way down
south west mm-hmm that's pretty cool
I wonder if you have any say over how
you where you start I mean it seems like
it's very obviously the same thing no
matter what but yeah I'm searching for a
hideout
Oh
we should probably pay attention I'm
going oh it's this way it's still I
guess okay
yeah I've got a scrawny nag - oh here we
go it's probably yeah all right yeah I'm
about to go talk to God just take it two
weeks off from this game and I forgot
like didn't control her yeah oh that was
weird
when I hitched my horse the horse
bonding went up by 10 like there's
different numbers in this I guess it's
usually just shows oh I thought that was
just a random person oh I'm about to
stealth my way through this whole camp
aw crap
they're gonna see your dead face and
just we're on fellas Oh Ben was telling
me this this is like so I can kill him
or take the mat I'm taking that mat
couldn't you kill him and then take it
back why it's a binary thing it's it's
tied to his hand yeah you run a
self-destruct thing that the CIA gave
him I mean can't I kill him now I have
the map
[Music]
you got six experience do you have honor
uh how do I tell ya I guess I kind of do
yeah but he didn't take any from you I
sure didn't because you I'm alluding to
I wouldn't be an outlaw in this I played
Arthur really honorable I've been
watching dirty Artie dough so like I've
seen how being an outlaw and that's
right can be in this game I killed that
guy weird all right I'm getting that
thing from Aiden so you could that's
something I heard you could do right it
is like do treasure maps with with your
buds scratch that see if the Eve's hitch
that never got scratched that wasn't low
below I don't know why I did that I'm
sorry okay cool so I'm about to go do
that so that so the question I'm doing
the gang height I was in Cumberland
Forest okay
oh there's goob I wonder what he'd show
up okay I'm gonna go do that hideout
if you want to switch to me just the
show how I don't know like I'm doing the
same quest just in Cumberland forest
near Valentine
so I just got that quest from a tandem
riding up to the woods
it's just Gavin my character oh I'm on
fire okay
so fitting we did not choose where we
started
yeah I don't know if it's tied to I mean
where this came Herrick tur he's coming
in Monday no I'm burned
oh you're burnt I'm burnt that's
horrifying
I felons I fell in the fire pit and now
I am light and a bunch of charcoals I
look like Deadpool thank you actually
look like a badass yeah he's sick if it
stayed like that but I'm gonna be ironic
he plays a really nice guy I'll do the
opposite
I'll be the luring grey haired maiden
all right there's a hideout somewhere
around here howdy partners where we look
in here where's this hideout
look for smoke yeah got it
good stealth my way in but that doesn't
seem like Gavin style yep
let's do it dismount why would she do
there we go
get off the horse red Ronin says what's
the character creation it's very similar
to GTL GTA online and funny enough it's
like the same kind of format of life of
the Dead I mean but in GTA online it's
just the same worse like you're in
prison and you get a mug shot in Rory
asking what's the dish that I do in this
I don't know yet you can't go I don't
even have it right yeah I think the
ability card you get so people are
saying obviously there's not gonna be
dead i but we had a stat that we put
that I into
here we go
how do I get off my horse it's not
letting me get off my horse you've been
hitting some bugs my friends go to go
maybe move around a little bit
really so earlier I had an audio bug so
everything else is working but I can't
get off the scrawny nag
I know how you can get off outdoors I
could just crash I guess try it that's
really weird I've never oh that's weird
there we go okay sweet so yeah so my
hideout was in Cumberland Forest yours
was down in the desert yeah probably
switched back to yours I'm just gonna be
talking to that guy oh wait we could I
could just I'm gonna kill this guy oh I
see that he looks different - yeah so I
want the map yes yes look at the map
it's just oh no I got it okay cool but I
got less honor I want to be an outlaw in
multiplayer do we I was if people are
just joining I was saying my Arthur was
very very honorable like toward the end
of the game I was maxed out and I'm
gonna cut to mine I just I just did you
found it yeah I used egg lie and and I
ranked up to 200 I got gold nuggets
so my treasure is near citadel rock kind
of a decent ride I'm gonna do some
looting first
hell yeah oh I discovered an ability
card alright I'm more excited to be an
outlaw in multiplayer personally just
because I've I don't know I liked good
Arthur
oh look Mike so this is I got a so these
are the cards while Deadeye is active
you oh I slowly regenerate health well
that's pretty cool
focus fireball Deadeye is active you and
your team members deal a little more
damage damn if more than one member of
your team has this ability active the
effects do not stack paint it black
while Deadeye is active you can paint
hard targets on two enemies fire your
weapon to shoot all marked targets each
shot drains dead I try that sounds like
the truest of yeah that makes sense for
PvE but like in PvP does it just
function in real time and you still
paint tar out of them we'll find out
that's cool-looking a little image there
I wonder if PvP stuff is that you even
available and um the beta yeah okay well
I'm gonna go look for that treasure so
what's interesting is that okay so yeah
oh yeah you can only equipped once so
ideally I Rob do you have another place
to put the pit by any chance right now
that's not that bad it's just this menu
I think nevermind
stop complaining goob so what's
interesting is yeah like if we had a
posse maybe you would take a different
Deadeye card right yeah if one of them
is like is gonna benefit the squad oh
yeah posse
but yeah you look like you can't take
more than one data card so that's just
the only one I get cool so you picked
painted black yeah I did Oh
Fox was limping poor guy
I'm really excited to see like what
people do in role playing in this game
like I was sheriff he won GTA 5 Rockstar
take that down though I say that again
I'm sorry didn't Rockstar take down like
sheriff Eli and RPG stuff on yea those
because I was using a mod right oh right
so it didn't look like there was a so
you didn't have the ability to
antagonize obviously cuz I would I would
require speaking because apparently all
characters all characters here don't
speak but you have emotes as like a
replacement
I believe I'm just messing with you goob
yeah so much oh it's starting to rain my
treasure is in near citadel rock for
those of you familiar with the
heartlands I'm riding there now I can
move the PIP I'll do that real quick and
then I'll put you on so you play your
audio is loud or too
god I know this game looks better on
Xbox one axe but it still looking pretty
good like it does up all right those
look good
so so it wasn't like it wasn't like it
wasn't story mode but the treasure is
like really in-depth or like the clues
were in depth because mine just showing
this area
search the treasure chest
'are you alright that this mountain bug
seems to have stopped
yeah alright
ability card voucher rank up all right
same thing as you
as expected who got a bunch of stuff we
get fence though yeah that's what I'm
you should get like a mission prompt to
now there's Gavin Gavin okay how do I
get to ability here we go um same stuff
I guess
yeah oh so there's dang okay so this
okay yeah I guess I mean that's that's
associated with rank right is kind of
like that regenerating health while a
minute you used paint a black one the
thing about that is if you get hit it
cancels I was interesting
while dead I is active you and your
teammates deal a little more damage if
more than one member of your team has
ass active ability the effects do not
stack yeah I'll use that do it be a team
player outlaw
cool wait did I put that oh I see got it
okay okay so look at okay does may be
able to put you in with like a so I'm
still curious yeah yeah so maybe it's
like fallout 76 in the sense that it's
still real time but it aims for you if
that makes sense yeah that does all
right I'm gonna go meet up with clay
Davies while you're doing that I'm
currently searching for players okay
maybe it just puts you into a match made
thing first before you can choose who
your posse is are we in the same server
/world not quite sure yet yeah I'm
almost willing to bet that like you do a
lot of the tutorial maybe in like a
private server bear with me while I
howdy
I can't here we go
just so you know these guys did nothing
to provoke me sounds about right
yeah it would be like that you like that
pip
here's what my screen looks like
oh Jesus Ben was saying that he was
getting disconnected fairly often oh
yeah so that's a bit different so
normally if I just came across random
guys in the world I would be able to aim
my gun but that acted like a dialog
prompt where I had to raise my gun like
with r2 as well if that made sense
because I don't think it was a diet like
yeah pack anyway pretty mom that's
pretty good reaction to that
I'm just gonna turn around and run yeah
kill it you didn't see [ __ ] okay okay
or like so yeah the witnessed system is
non-existent - right it said it was if I
kept doing stuff but it was definitely
not like those guys would have gotten to
share if I was in single-player so you
got disconnected did it put you back at
your camp it looks like yeah it put me
back god I miss my horse it put me back
where this matchmaking
it's basically tutorial izing
matchmaking I guess so like is that your
camp right there it's a story mission
gotcha okay one to four players you're
you're probably about to do the same
thing yeah start matchmaking or you are
doing the same thing yeah so from what
Ben was saying I think you do have to do
with randos first hopefully we don't get
and yeah it's kind of like Rainbow six
yeah okay I'm getting loaded into one
now that'd be pretty funny if we know
what's your character's name I think
it's Bobby real creative Big Bob that
kind of left looks kind of cool he's got
the scars weapon loadout to have any
just cattlemen right now yeah I mean all
just ready uh-huh they're gonna do any
different here purchases huh so this is
cool before missions you set up he don't
talk neither do we these are the horse
things you mean sorry part of the roads
chapter it's not good people they're out
at Rathskeller Fork with a bunch of
horses they stole from me well that's a
lot but they stole them off a fella
I was gonna steal him off of maybe you
could get them for me
look here are your friends
well good meet me at the stable at
tumbleweed once you have the horse flash
and I'll pay you good oh and pop poorly
wanted me to remind you any decent work
you can find take it but just try to
stay out of trouble oh and once you give
me those horses
well after that we'll talk again oh I do
so enjoy these conversations I'm used to
am own account of my brother
let's go club
clive just had imaginary reins wait yeah
Claude you son-of-a-bitch huge son of a
gun
dirty dog all right so we're gonna steal
a horse we're on the same mission yeah
what's interesting is go boys you're in
a different area right I wonder if it
matched me up based on like the starting
area that person just lost to off their
horse I think all right cool are they
going
all right surprise this is interesting
hey watch it
I wonder if you oh here we go
yeah we're at the same spot as well
[Music]
are these damn horses
quit loom bodies let's go
nice
so dead I didn't slow down or anything I
don't know oh I didn't even try it I
tried it it didn't so free yeah it
doesn't slow time obviously and put it I
don't like obviously it's dependent on
your ability card but stealing these
horsies oh no I want the big one come on
the big one keep that big horse oh you
still to calm them and everything I
forgot to share kentucky saddler
how's a bug these guys doing
yeah you can pat your horse yeah I had
to call minor for stolen
so how does dead IO work well so there's
not sure I just did I just activated it
so it I mean I'm assuming I get my Oh
people in your squad for those at who
are asking I can show you in a second
but you have basically start off it
looks like with a few different cards or
like types of Deadeye that you can
activate at once so I just have the
ability to target people by traditional
Deadeye mine ups my team's damage yeah
there's like damage boosting ones you
know I forgot what the other one is you
regenerate your own health when you're
in it as long as you don't get shot
right it takes you out of it once you do
so our third guys kind of lagging behind
but me and this guy are yeah one of our
one of the people in my match sure was
just looting the bodies at the good at
the stable it came from the 80s asks how
does voice chat work not quite sure yet
man these guys are really trying to
everybody get out of here with these
cars
nice to meet you know what boy
I call him because I'm older oh man
alright I'm out of a bar friend here
back to horse yeah I got that's what I
got
tried to get the better horse when I was
in the stable my horse has seen some
nice horse
hopefully I'm open I'm out of this team
you want to get with you guys
so I'm going back to Valentine Aaron
asks what's your favorite guns I I'm I'm
a fan of the Lancaster repeater like
that one oh look I'm a double-barrel
shotgun guy
yeah just like GG online you get hoarse
or insurance so we're at the same we're
at the same spot I got some money well I
guess this is free insurance and so
that'll bring you back that horse if it
dies mm-hmm that would've been nice in
single-player I'm gonna name my horse
Carl or karaoke and karaoke and I'm
gonna get this this horse care package
like jaundice nice meeting you too
oh so we did you get the horse that you
stole or they give you a different one
no I got the one I I stole so I'm doing
that right now yeah so these are so
someone mentioned one of the prison
guards earlier and these two dudes Clive
and his brother are from the
singleplayer mm-hmm I've heard some
other pretty big characters will be
introduced later yeah like Sadie I think
so a lot of this is locked behind what
you call a rank and now you're also
seeing the effects of some gold here
which is I'm assuming this the mitral
microtransactions right bye-bye actual
gold yeah wish I named my horse uh Gavin
everything Gavin
cool all right so I I want it for
nearing the point where we can probably
meet up and start doing stuff I hope so
yeah so I'm gonna put a saddle on
everything wait why don't I have
gotcha okay here we go someone's asking
about Deadeye so I'll show it so as you
see here in the top right you go to
loadout and you can swap I mean I guess
by rank 10 you'll have a new passive
card there but currently there's like
three types of Deadeye I'll have this
one you can only have one active at a
time so I have this one which is the
ability to like paint targets and then
this one affects team members as well as
you you have a damage boost doesn't
stack so you can't like all engage in
have insane mod damage and then this one
is the ability to regenerate health
while in Deadeye if you get hit though
it disengages okay so how big is the
maps as g1 gaming it's the map just the
map of read dead 2 we start in different
places yeah yeah cool so that feels good
to have a new horse mm-hmm my horse
Gavin and my rider Gavin so I'm going to
meet Crips at camp as well yeah yeah I'm
good not too not the fastest horse not
bad though just gonna up that bonding
yeah I really want that skid mm-hmm at
level three
yeah did you ever use the that like peel
out whatever was what's that oh yeah you
were trying to first now you get you you
or no no sorry
no the the first thing you get when the
horse just like neighs and goes on its
back legs before you take off oh right
I've never used it now I think you're
just more for style yeah I'm just I'm
back on my camp here I guess so the
horse insurance allows your horse to
automatically recover over time it's
critically injured but the same thing as
car stuff and yeah it's same thing as GT
online so if like you know in the event
of someone killing your horse you're
able to get it back again your horse is
pretty black than the way main this also
takes place before red dead - so it's a
prequel to the prequel packs ass can you
swim weed I'm sure you can don't know
yet though we know marcin he wants you
to come down and meet him in black water
when you get a chance I think you might
have some work for you oh and while
you're out on your travels you may see
some folk with employment opportunities
good for bad folk looking for a tough
guy with a gun this is a help up to you
if you listen to him yes you know I I
used to like that kind of stuff one time
I almost helped a clown steer an
elephant make yourself at home it is
your home don't know how many years
before the story it is can't be too long
we've seen several characters who are
like the same age so I think it's
relatively shortly before read that - oh
that's me
all right this seems to really open up
now I think I think this is a dude type
counter arrival players missions you
could be like the law Oh
now there you go so I think yeah I'm
almost done with this cutscene okay when
you're done do you want to see if I can
invite you yeah I wonder if Lucy and Ben
are around the same point as us well Ben
definitely is yeah there you go
nice Oh Jake's here Jake's here too okay
let's try I mean are we not friends
oh they said they haven't finished the
intermission this should work for him
and it bends done I doubt I'd out Jake's
done but we'll see oh maybe he's done I
don't think we're friends
really all right let me uh Lucy's not
venez all right
let me cut to you and double check on
nope still hate each other there we go
yeah we're friends you might maybe I was
in the end maybe it was just I see you
right here okay well it might have just
been because we were I was in the
cutscene I just invited you or do you
want me to come here yeah come to me
because I can you invite I don't know if
I could just join let me just you see
Posse oh I got a bonus invites you don't
pop up and my friends you're popping up
in mind you are you uh are you hidden
maybe you want to double check
I'm definitely am that's why sorry are
you good I did did that be when we got
review coach it's good right oh yeah for
sure I did the same um set online status
I'm on a little showing up now alright
so you can rest and craft and cook by
the campfire check now or do I have to
go like fully into the hidden games
thing shut your mouth yeah there you go
that was it okay I invited you hopefully
that works yeah
see what kind of emotions can get for
you Rome right now
yeah defending your game yes I invited
him we'll see what happens let's do a
hideout yeah I'll still hide out when
you get in what are these icons is that
your strangers so I'm in your world I
think I just got a you don't show up on
the map I'm in the desert
oh I'm near you oh you're here
you're totally here howdy partner look
at got ourselves a sweet little Posse
here hey fellas [ __ ] already I'm gonna
[ __ ] choke her out okay stop it stop
it great so fun you'll come back and
meantime I'm gonna get rid of your body
here
um Wow when you come back don't look at
your body okay okay now where are you
guys
how come I don't see you trying to see
you on the map raise or lower the fly
what's that about is there a way to see
you on the map
no can you open your map just so I can
see where you are okay
yeah you want to go oh that okay I see
you I thought that those were enemies
the pink okay cool yeah who else is in
our game beside you two just been so
let's see here can't cook anything
probably need to kill some stuff revenge
huh yeah it's throw that body right oh
no that's too I'm taking him with me
okay so what's army alright let's wait
for bed now okay and what's this over
here my hat back on Oh wardrobe okay
where's my hat
[Music]
there's beer here have a beer
Wow there's my hat all right sweet okay
enough we're even now you guys alright
Ben oh you got disconnected there's a
certain point where we're even want me
to buy you again yeah please
so I wonder so Lucy still hasn't
finished yet Lucy hurry up and finish I
wonder if we can create a crew maybe
that's not a possum oh yeah you got to
go to UM press square now to create your
own type I let's try this persistent oh
wow
so $200 in order to have a persistent
posse sorry
oh so that's like clan yeah when you
pick your camp should be able invite me
now or when you get the chance
okay firmly [ __ ] I contemporary make do
a temporary one right here that's kind
of that's weird
my horse is nowhere near me that's gonna
keep doing this
alright well I'll just do Ben and you
like just straight I did without my
horse okay all right I sent oh it right
just passi and two sessions I did it
both there oh you're in my server there
should be oh cool so he is now in my
posse hence he's blue
all right let's what's this this is your
Posse joining failed alright well I
don't know what to do about that
sorry you are already in the same
session as the inviting player what
you're hearing out here maybe you just
have to invite me just to the posse now
yeah let's see about that
yeah I should work alright sweet
I just don't have a horse there yes cool
all right so let's go I want to do that
hideout maybe start oh it's gone there's
Oller there's already dudes here shoo go
kill these guys yeah we could try will
that let us yeah let's do it
all right let's do it show these goes
who is this someone should have the uh
sorry I just Oh so my dad I will give us
all damage boost I don't know Ben's in
the chat
Lucy's done do you want to add her okay
can have up to seven people I believe
let's wait for her though it's so
awkward whenever was just a mute doing
cycling
alright maybe Lucy's in now I really
wanna kill these guys
yeah oh do you see that well that dudes
voice chat just popped up here oh yeah
eysan I thought I did hear that I didn't
see it oh yeah its proximity chat I
guess once the Lucy gets in we can go oh
no I want to be out loud yeah what are
we were you a good posse bad posse well
we're about to be real bad because we're
gonna kill those fools at least you said
unable to join I can try again so work
for me when I went into the session
first and then the posse yeah I didn't
invite her to the posse Adam did you
notice that you can sit you can do the
the pistol trick still which is perfect
how you just double tap l along with the
power nice take it on your horse oh I
can look I can get on that's not his
real horse though oh really
says Lucy's processing oh she was here
for a second I think there she is up she
she's fading in and out oh don't kill
her I didn't I was shooting the gun in
the air all right let's try it says
she's that's super weird I was fighting
the fire got in the air but it
registered her as my enemy all right up
a scene oh yeah she's coming off as an
enemy sweet all right oh nice their
horse is right there alright everyone
get ready
I wonder if they're still there they
can't be right Night Stalker whatever
his name was they don't they don't seem
to be together we're we're gonna kill
this guy doesn't I it's Night Stalker
alright so I wonder if I could just hold
X and ride with you oh yeah it seems
like a let's ride is it bring me with
you or oh here we go here we are boys
this is a mess yeah this is our time
this is our town sorry fella you're real
close to my camp
what'd you get for messing with dirty
Gavin and the boys I'm gonna put him on
the back of my horse as a trophy
so the dead ice definitely gave us more
damage there because we really wrecked
them you gauged it yeah yeah put that
put that trophy on your horse there
partner
can we skin this for parts all right
who's next
there's someone over here well we better
go get them oh it's nice oh witness
witness on where I don't know it says
there's a witness though murder on our
level
well good fine I'm working my way down
this cliff all right what are we gonna
do next
the Benz horse is dead all right all
right I don't know how you guys got down
there geez I I kind of just jumped so it
looks like yeah the same people are
respawning so we are in the same session
oh I wonder if you can get on my horse
to me revive your horse Oh could you let
me yeah let me take this dude off I've
had my fun with this body oh this
doesn't look good everything okay there
Ben see if he ODS too late no I want to
see if he can get on my horse actually
I'll see if I can uh Ben's now can't
share horse oh oh oh that's awesome kind
of all right I'm gonna go my horse stuff
but that's good to know
all right so let's now go Oh someone's
coming night star I feel Oh Ben got this
tunic connected I'll invite him let's go
to tumbleweed and check out the town
okay nice starts coming he's right here
shriek killing again he's right there if
you engage right here no let's engage
yes yeah he's shooting at us you mess
with Kissin Kate Barlow oh you think
you're so special huh that guy's gonna
be mad
alright so you couldn't loot him huh I
did not try but they're not showing up
as X's on the maps I don't think I
wonder friend just got disconnected or
something oh right I'm sorry oh and by
you again Ben oh wait wait wait wait
watch this watch wait
oh I just said I could night stars well
let's go to town
wait wait come here it's giving me the
option to jump to your horse oh please
oh oh yeah there it is I saw it keeps
going away you get to be like alongside
me or something we might be moving oh
dang the posse was abandoned and
abandoned or getting disconnected well
if you even know I guess yeah he wasn't
still going after me he's pissed you
want to invite or don't do it yet oh
that's Lucy sorry sorry
sorry Lucy I thought that was night star
Bruno asks is the map the same it is so
far it's the exact same map ghosts asked
is the beta out yes this is the first
release for people who have the ultimate
edition of Red Dead Redemption - you're
able to join today if you purchase and
played the game on launch you'll be able
to play tomorrow and I think subsequent
release days after that until Friday who
where everyone who owns the game is able
to play Lucy got kicked why don't I do
it so me and Lucy were still in the
posse she said she got kicked just now
uh-oh I mean about you guys this timer
same thing using by me I guess I already
have one I can invite you guys yeah do
it form a posse temporary invite only
friendly fire off okay
I'm gonna fight you guys John Doe asks
how much fun is there Finn is this I'm
assuming he says oh yeah he said fun
invite see alright I'll do so far it's
it's been pretty neat we kind of just
opened up there's kind of the I would
say the tutorial of the G here we go he
points to GTA online Red Dead online is
like kind of lengthy it's like an
hour-ish it took us to like get to the
open world where you can like do all
this posse and clan stuff with your
buddies so we are now joining Mike so I
just realized that I'm not friends have
been actually oh well let's see if well
that's fine well see if I can you should
be able to do recent players I don't
know if that works no it doesn't well
let me see if I can invite them oh never
that was it go back yeah recent players
yeah alright there's been your in mind
it looks like I sent one to Lucy
it looks like you guys are joining
there's you so now send me a posse
that's what I thought oh right yeah I
sent you a posse is this who is this is
this just took my horse Jake Jake's in
now where's my horse
okay so Joe I got invite Jake posse
members oh you can only four people in
this posse friends there's two invited
Jake recent players everyone what
something Jesus I sent you guys invites
to the posse Lucy's in my posse yeah I
just got it now Jake isn't my posse my
horse is over here I guess there's Carl
or so it looks like you two are in it so
it's only showing room for four right
now Ben's not in it right now yeah see
there's only four spots for a posse are
you sure on that
look it maybe I could change settings go
or maybe no I thought it was like seven
go back to so I sent him an invite but
members-only showing four slots my
reputation is dishonesty is full so
he'll just ride along ok ok so let's go
why don't why don't we go to town ok
tumbleweed or we could go watch out for
night star there's a hideout you want to
do that highlight the hideout so go to
your map and it looks like it's north of
us yeah let's go there
Oh your marker shows up for us to which
I cool that's right that's cool so I can
I can match my speed to you so wonderful
like if you're not in the pots you won't
get certain rewards or something
there's no friendly fire on Capote watch
out for don't you bend because oh [ __ ]
oh this is the this is the hideout
I'm supposed to barrel
that's really annoying my auto-aim is
picking Ben up oh geez sorry Ben my auto
aim is tickin him up yeah I worked out
oh this dog just pulled me off my yeah
that dog is an enemy oh no it's my horse
down you gonna revive him okay yeah man
that's yeah see Ben's showing up as a
enemy no he is yeah cuz I I did like my
Auto and picks him up even when he
wasn't that's everyone
that's everyone right what is oh here's
another one pick up dog
[Applause]
take out the enemies what other enemies
are still whose dog is this what should
I do with this dog but did I do it this
poor job
do you know a good vet someone help me
are we gonna do all right
hideout cleared nice job looks weird
stand back to blow the dog up Jake it
back hmm
get back Jake get out of there run Jake
bend up hold and do all was it done yeah
I guess so
all right cool well I guess we did that
there's been okay I'll go to town now
yeah let's go town I think I mean I I
would assume Posse leader I would assume
we all have like gold rings and stuff to
sell to a fence right yeah but there's
no fence in tumbleweed doesn't oh yeah
there is no that's general Starr maybe
you can sell to him or there's what's
this showdown series horse race
they're just stranger it let's go to
town yeah I want to see the town see we
can do there
all right hmm what's read okay who put
this body on my horse
probably Jake going this way a
tumbleweed you think the the town
sheriff will mind this dead body
no sir you guys try first-person mode
yeah I'm doing it right now
hey everyone fine everyone fire your gun
in the air yeah right no sick
Jake fire your gun in the air you can do
it man I don't use first-person often oh
I made it wrong there is first person
first person is very hard bossy all
right
his money hard to come by uh it's hard
oh well that's weird we both got this
connected fully just when we were just
way way I'm gonna see how it works if I
just go posse up straight from this menu
rats
yeah if anybody's just joining in the
last few minutes or so I'm Mike this is
Rob
we're playing read that online beta B if
you have the Ultimate Edition it should
be live for you now
if you preorder The Ultimate Edition or
like yeah if you have the Ultimate
Edition if you play it on launch day and
you don't have the ultimate ition so
like late tonight tomorrow morning it'll
be available we've had a few bugs we got
disconnected we had a posse for members
max lost our friend Ben Janka Lucy James
and Jake Decker also playing in the
office but yeah we got disconnected
quite a few times I had a weird audio oh
this could be bad Mike go ahead and mute
around online let me see if I can follow
me man
Kevin at least sir social settings and
you go no no you would go to the player
go to the no no back out Kevin Kevin
all right back out back out and I'm
sorry right on the d-pad but there again
Gavin there's again right on a left left
on the d-pad excuse me butter players
and then they're mute all trying it back
[Music]
oh did you just join a random posses
that oh no I joined this for oh I did
yeah you did
oh I just got disconnected my okay [ __ ]
can i buy [ __ ] from here that's kind of
cool
yeah I mean someone else's Posse that's
why I heard them let me abandon this
Posse I'm just going to abandon I'm
gonna do free roam and then I'm gonna
fight everyone okay see that cuz heck oh
[ __ ] is Gavin that is a good thing to
test unfortunately we don't have mics in
here Farley's PS playstation mics
Michael NS use the mic and see if your
characters mouth moves when you talk I
would assume it would just like Grand
Theft Auto online so I would turn auto
aim off can I actually that's good tria
vague asks can you turn auto aim off try
probably you probably still can
targeting lock-on mode on foot so I yeah
yeah I guess so I'm gonna keep it on in
case PvP dudes come up to me but uh
alright you said you're gonna invite me
when you gonna yeah I'm gonna do that
right now yeah I want to get some new
wait what's my money like two dollars
and 37 cents alright so I sent invites
to the crew here I also soften the menu
you can choose where what area to start
in in free room
did you get that invite okay cool all
right so I am in your session now I just
got to join your posse if you send me
then all right so let's try that now
whoops how this wish to mind players
friends pointing a gun of it hey what
the heck
guys trying to show this game I'm yo
dudes trying to trying to alright we get
it it's funny stop and are you guys in a
posse already know or not this is just
who's joining this it's been then
stopped and then he sent you away in the
horse
alright oh you can break free look at
that it takes a while but you can break
free from the the rope or you can die
that's that's a nice option that's my
horse
- did you send me a posse bite let me
try again I feel like oh I have to
create a temp I could create a temporary
one the first set on the first mute all
these people and then I'm gonna create a
posse
all right let's see if that works
all right it smell great
oh my horse bonding level went up from
great my hats gone cuz you guys beat me
up don't involve me I was I was just an
odd bystander alright who we got here
Jake my controller we're all here mm-hmm
except for Lucy right
yeah she's it looks like she's nearby
Ben's not in it anymore
no it should be like this Center I sent
her a posse invited I'll see what
happens to her oh look a bird alright
Lucy's in it
when I go to town or do you wanna like
yeah I wanna I still want to go this
town we haven't done that yet right this
way I'll open my map and put a marker
now Jake just left the posse he's got
kicked yeah looks like it
alright I'm right behind you oh I got
the drift now did you I got well I got
horse no I got horse funding level two I
don't think I should have drift yet well
if there's anything we learned from the
beta is that it is not entirely that
stable oh you can hold X oh so I was
just saying I hope you can match speed I
can match speed with a Posse leader as
long as I'm holding ax near you
interesting
all right well I'm going to the town
Lucy doesn't ever horse but let's oh
we'll pick her up oh yeah
Lucy get on wait she's showing up next
to us what the yeah she's that's weird
she's a ghost alright alright well let's
just keep ridin maybe she'll reappear
we're outside tumbleweed yeah she's just
said that she's we're on the map but not
in her game
it's weird maybe she'll show up rabbit
dear dude
all right hopefully this game doesn't
crash when we approach this town we'll
see I can just match speed with you as
long as you're the leader that's neat
it's helpful bird oh wait oh man
oh I could have just jumped your horse
for your match speed let me do that I'm
gonna ride up next to you wanky moving
let's jump the horse there we go hi hey
hey hi okay I'm out I only have two
dollars and 37 cents so I don't have
many options economically Todd pop out
others take take the whole map it is the
whole map Oh eat Jason yeah all right so
let me see about and there's been some
Jake's an enemy right now cuz he just
shoved me go to the general store and
see if you see me looking at a cat
looking at a catalog I wonder how that
would work if you want it to look at a
catalog too or you have to wait oh I
just go away
yeah so you can look at a catalog
anywhere in multiplayer that's what I
opened up before you just hold all right
hold it what did I do
hold left yeah hold left and then I just
get this I don't know if it's oh that's
kind of weird Jake just got kicked
oh so yeah I could just buy any of these
straight from this mobile catalog you'd
be smart to stock up here before you hit
the road
Jesus leave this this one is we could be
the most dapper gang as [ __ ] this is a I
wonder what I bet the conversion is a
dollar leave this one I'd be either
ranked 92 or I'd probably pay like 19
bucks for this fit these fits are
expansive what's this oh man that is hot
this is also not appropriate for the
climate those outfits are special
outfits sir these are outfits so let's
see what we'll see what a new hat would
be man you can't get any of these hats
without being like a rank
so it's interesting how some of them are
our locks boot behind a rank or you know
spend the money Oh what's this military
scout had to get that all right we're
gonna see what that stranger was doing
that's a good idea
yeah I'm kind of this isn't very fun is
it just looking at a catalogue well cool
that works see you guys here's my horse
oh nice parking job well Suzuki okay we
go to the bar and get drunk oh I hope so
drinks are on you though I have a just
two dollars and 37 cents get off the
floor
you want to start a brawl yay yeah let's
get a drinking that's yeah not everyone
yeah let's get rocked and then let's get
rocked one for you
whiskey spend all my money on this oh
yeah give me the whole bottle Thanks
[Music]
they know shits gonna go - who's this oh
it's I got another bottle
[Music]
benzine and our Posse ii yeah he's gonna
well I sent a pot a posse invite to both
of them so we'll see who can do it quick
I'm cook enough put your thumb down how
am I not drunk yet oh I am no I'm not
check this out it's on it's on oh god yo
it he was shooting who start to shot oh
this is the sheriff I'm punching
goddamnit that was the sheriff and his
deputies we spawned me outside of town
[Music]
how'd you survive I'm right I'm coming
back I'm here
look who's back oh the police the police
are coming so they don't remember me
which is oh those guys still playing the
piano oh I'm out of here
who's shooting oh I'm dead I got you I
got you oh never mind
yeah so I had the option to revive you
how interesting oh my god they're all
coming they did not like me shooting
that deputy where's my horse it sound
like Arthur who he's chasing me
where's Gavin oh yeah Ned Flanders just
the laugh-out-loud the pianist still
playing where is my horse obey the law
obey the law
Oh manuals dead why is my horse not
coming run there's people back there
also the whole time Lucy has just been a
ghost like I want to say she's been
participating we haven't been seeing
alright they're done searching but why
is my horse not listening to me all they
found me there is there is what took you
so long
Gavin go go go go alright now alright I
think I'm gonna put a new waypoint let's
see if we can do are you still alive no
I died and respond oh jeez
dead end what else can we do here
let's try this stranger yeah let's see
what they do yeah I see it that that is
cool that it just does it for everybody
yeah it even shows me like the path
oh there's no there's been yeah I'm
gonna I'll meet you guys there so I'm
not allowed back in tumbleweed for a
while how did they find me again I'm
bringing some heat with me just so you
guys know
oh they're you I'm right behind you as
it's the law whoa lightning
I didn't keep finding me 1 Mississippi 2
Mississippi 3 and see that's X 3 miles
away
this they keep finding me Wow
how about this thunderstorm huh
my horse is tired from running
good call this be fine no I got no the
food friend
uh-oh rival posse started a mission
getting controlled otário we're attacked
the posse gained control the target uh
you want to do this I think he's in
there right now the bag am I gonna do
this
yeah all right this guy's dude in here
yeah let's do it is he behind the
building or in it behind it
just sitting on this oh he's over here
oh it's uh where is he oh it's a oh it's
on yeah it's my red bag Oh get it I got
one there's another one to thank oh he's
got it the other guy's got it okay take
it up here no he's what what he's gone
no no it's it just I picked I have one
yeah I got one
oh I see he's on the run so there's got
two possible ones but I had the other
one I'm gonna get this I'm going after
this guy who wants to get on my horse
oh we get on right behind you hi let's
go get him so I've got one bag someone
else has the other one yeah the red one
I think Lucy does but she's invisible so
do what you want to deliver this one
also go get the other one Lucy Lucy
should go deliver it oh this guys are
here oh he's shooting me I've got the
bag and he's dead thank you Jake just
saved me yeah let's get his bag bring
him both back all right Jackson a guy's
body just his body just flipped out damn
he was going for me hard I need to eat
something
oh they got me I'm down
oh no you responded really close so did
I someone get me someone get me I'm
dying so we both have the bag now but
there Carlos oh nice then then isn't it
unfortunately not in our I'll see you
ask the thing that's annoying they just
spawn right really close to us
flights out
dropo I automatically picked it up yeah
damnit yeah it wasn't let me aim I was
kind of weird they do spawn close that's
too close
Jake
oh [ __ ] this dude I got yeah let's see
the bag or what all right we should get
out of here yeah let's go no there's one
on the road right here but yeah there
Jake's getting one all right yeah let's
just get out of here because those guys
are spawning really close by this way we
also don't have much time
oh I'm following your Waypoint oh [ __ ]
what you should have I think we're okay
I don't even see where we're delivering
these
so Lucy the lucy delivered one she's
still like a ghost in my game for
everyone she is so we just keep doing
bags on hi oh let's do this one
Jake's got kicked nah [ __ ] yeah that was
that sucks he had a bag too
oh this is not my horse oh really
but I have a Pelt on here pick up back
okay there's another one over here
yeah I was gonna say Jake said he got
kicked him right before he's about to
deliver the second one man I'm right
near it
all right I met this bag
No pick it up
all right I got this bag I'm gonna go
deliver it people are probably gonna be
coming after me
Lucy's right near me but
yeah I'm coming where's this recipient
is it just at the town where is it even
on them no goddamn man it's like a
hideout somewhere but it's oh it's kind
of far
someone's look like someone's kinda
gonna have to you probably are no I got
it hello got it
can they kill me right now sweet thanks
sweet bag stolen ooh
got some money there $5.00 bad split
shouldn't like a military jacket and a
pump-action shotgun from hitting level 5
well they're available so what now
should we my mute that guy oh right
sorry oh [ __ ] someone killing me
who is this Jake just kicked me off my
damn horse get off my horse dude still
as music horse I'll come find you
whoever's horse I stole had a pelt on it
things are going well
oh that was Jake yeah okay now what was
I doing again let's look at the matter
look at that stranger yes let's do that
uh south of here kind of ways out that
yeah I see someone's there a couple guys
are their shirts do it anyway
sure so you you want to put a waypoint
yeah I just yeah this is my horse all
right
don't opposite way sign homeopathy
and I'll cut across this way
I've not been paying attention my cores
at all yeah yeah it really makes you
want to like I mean just obviously like
actual game a lot of horses here Jesus
how I see it
cool makes you want to like really stock
up you know I mean like I have like no
horse food so it's just weird think
about eating one like another player
could just shoot you at any moment yeah
I get me quick
can you give items I don't know
there's discard I don't think so
house chicken
oh guy your left
Happy's following us or not oh yeah that
was the different before good so we're
here so I think this is the same
stranger is he gonna give us the same
mission that like that a guy started no
let's see
he's inside I think good morning [ __ ]
there are a lot of people nearby you
know it's different it's a caravan
escort so let's do it but you never can
tell for sure okay let's get you over
there all right
oh [ __ ] look alive so you better cover
me where's my gun or your oh you're
driving I'm covering you oh I just kept
he's in a posse oh I didn't mean that
Oh oh man well this is a little
difficult yeah there there's a posse
already near us
that was Ben we had we have to get back
on the caravan and just keep going I
guess they respawn you so close the
rival players can attack caravan that
[ __ ] this is not gonna go well I'm with
you kill this guy
oh wait wait we need that one smooth all
right I'm coming I'm out of here
oh man we have no escort go go go go go
go throw his dead body go yeah just
bring that one
I don't know they might catch up if they
get a horse can't look at your map are
they close they're close to me not you
know I gotta keep focusing on driving
I think there's camping out here though
so here's a tip don't engage a stranger
when there's three other guys just
waiting for you
this same dude keeps crap shooting us
God that same dude
I got this feeling that I'm gonna get
caught up to
I'm gonna let that be [ __ ] weed out so I
can who are these guys go goddamnit you
respond very quickly in this game
oh they they took on the other ones yes
I'm near them still you know they didn't
this doesn't seem does it seem like
you're making much progress does it no
or anyone for that matter later group
dang this whole posses over here oh my
god let's go let you deliver that yeah
you just getting rocked yeah no I mean
we're all killing each other and
respawning it right it's just like a
leapfrog yeah I'm not even gonna bother
with that one and they're still shooting
I don't want to respond to them
this seems a bit broken it's a little
broken I mean yeah like if you have to
like if you have to like wait or only do
stranger missions when no one else is
around that's kind of frustrating yeah
hey deliver the wagons but there's SiC
three more guys over this way we have to
wait eight minutes till the missions
done I guess oh that was an MPC I'm just
riffing come help you guys but now my
horse isn't even here I don't I'm gonna
have a horse rats
get binoculars
oh whoa you try to laugh
oh it's been sorry Ben sorry I don't
want to respawn over here but it keeps
respawning me here yeah that's like GTA
online man
unfortunately there we go
someone delivered it that's fine
get any money I don't know
I didn't notice do we get anything did
we get anything with the heck no what
the Frick
you know what's annoying is that you
have to like oh I guess if you put your
gun down I guess you can do someone's on
my horse okay someone's on your horse
yeah [ __ ] Wow my horse took forever but
it's here oh that's not my horse are you
getting rocked we're gonna come help you
it's yeah let's go have him been sitting
for fun anymore excited just based upon
me near them yeah well that was a that
was a something that was wrong with
frustrating aspects of GTA online is
like that could continually happen like
I'm whistling my horse is coming to me
but there's someone on it
yeah that's not cool
are we in single-player no this is um
the Red Dead online beta go kill some
chickens we could try doing that oh you
got kicked then got kicked man who's
this
oh it's Lucy come on Lucy you're not a
ghost anymore
are you still getting rocks no it just
can't get my horse now because they're
doing that wagon thing and he's got my
horse got my horse back at least kill
the guy on it I just want to get the
[ __ ] out of here so I can meet up with
you I'll come find you I'm finally out
yeah dang I need some provisions for my
horse yeah I'm kind of in the same boat
want to go farther away from here like
into the heartlands maybe yeah I'm down
for that let's make a little expedition
so let's go like maybe McFarland's ranch
true or late wait there's a stranger in
McFarland all right you wanna do that
I'll say we go to Blackwater man this I
just wonder who this who the quest giver
would be it McFarland's a ranch
let's just check I don't know see if
it's anybody we know there's a mission
at Blackwater okay
like a story mission we could try that
sounds let's go let's go to McFarland's
ranch first god damn it just shooting
you I don't know how I'm gonna stay here
dad oh it tells you how you died yeah
horse [ __ ] damn [ __ ] I'm getting my
horse let's yeah let's I'm just gonna oh
yeah black waters or like gonna pick
parlons ranch yeah or I'll follow the
waypoint meet you guys there
oh god damn another here oh my god I see
him I'm not fun
Lucy's just Lucy just got shot damn dude
sick response yeah wow I spawned real
quick yeah they should leave the
cooldown way longer than what it is
he's about yeah you're liking it yeah it
was I was enjoying until like we got in
this turf war but this Posse well let's
just we could just run there hey my
stamina went up
how does Dead Eye work there's like
three types of dead I you have cards and
you can only choose one and they're like
different features so like one I have is
the ability just to paint targets
there's one that's like boost your
damage isn't the one that like boosts
your health yeah that's the one I'm
using that's when Mike is using is the
damaged one right yes but there's no
slow-mo which would make sense first
something online god these guys just
they're not are they still following us
yeah I think there's my horse
there's my horse but these guys are
right behind us there's Lucy I just
really go oh
there's Carl or yeah I don't like that
it shows where the other players are you
don't like that like I mean if like if
you get into a situation like this they
know exactly where yeah they know
exactly where you are I mean it could be
good for like I don't know it could be
good for just like linking up with other
people side arms kill challenge did you
do that I think it's just it's just like
we're near it or some [ __ ] like that are
you in cinematic mode yeah
stop whistling like crazy well I just
want my horse
it's working
Oh is someone following is this behind
this
oh it's been looks like I'm finally in
the clear
alright let's go to McFarland's ranch I
still haven't gotten there yet and
singleplayer oh really yeah
that's the same map as singleplayer beer
bearded beaver what i realized what i
said what i don't if i am i behind you
or in front of you or i don't know i
don't know where you are my core is are
drained
dude this maps very big yeah already I
can't tell us everything like the rate
well the problem you know is I feel like
people are consistently filtering in and
out of the server and I don't know if
it's been accounting for it cuz I've
done that like three times yeah
oh it's armadillo
[Music]
wait I said corresponding level three
achieve but I don't have the drift
square in r1 right no triangle no let's
get off your horse I'm sorry
X you do X and r1 neither one is working
[Music]
Mario says horse riding is so boring do
something well it's kind of what the
horse riding gets you to do yeah you
kind of have to stick with it in order
to get somewhere cool we're also trying
to get out of the area because it's I'm
getting bored of the desert so we're
heading to McFarland's ranch hopefully
there's something there drifting is
until 4:00 I thought drifting was three
and then four was like four is the
drifting but three is the skid skid the
brake I should have the ebrake
my horse is not happy now no it's not I
haven't even really fed a while I also
haven't been like take like getting a
little little Pat's
I could just jump to this random guys
horse
a baby
who is this
it's Ben hey Ben just go into the
objective on foot and you can get on the
hill he's taking this guy's horse yeah
he is
I'll finish him off or you kill been no
bed just just just through this guy off
the horse and just killed him as he lay
on the ground and it's just very much
red dead where's my hat I don't know you
know what's a bummer is I lost my hat my
hat due to someone beating me up and I'm
not really able to like pull it back on
like your bags
whoa you know that's that's the guy been
killed dude you're passing oh that's a
lot of Apple those are all NPCs oh those
are guys huh so I'm not that far behind
you guys and now you're you're super
close actually
can you camp yeah you can camp
nice jump Ben
yeah there I think I think I see you
yeah they're right but we're right
behind you no I can't go that fast cause
I'm coming for you
I don't think they're coming for me
there one that's I don't know it's like
those two on one horse and then you too
like he also is not on his horse is a
horse right here Ben right behind Oh Ben
Ben Ben knows he wanted to ride up with
me
that looks sick and he's got a cool fit
he likes you now can you stand on the
horseback no I don't think so I'm moving
too fast put the hat on
well that's not true like I I guess I
didn't explain what I was saying but
like I don't have the ability like here
should be the ability to put the hat on
hats empty I don't know what happened I
won't almost want to say it's a bug or
just you I don't know maybe it doesn't
register the Alpha in the cell the
outfits in the saddlebag right the whole
outfit I figured I could put that on
because you could do that in
single-player you put that on then the
hole and then it just kind of resets
over here here let's try not to start
[ __ ] with these guys I would like to do
this yeah pick a [ __ ] really
we just wave at the same exact night oh
it's someone nice that's nice oh he's
got a pump-action shotgun I don't wanna
mess with him
it'd also be cool if you could warp to a
player holy [ __ ]
is that Bonnie yeah it is that's sick so
you have to get the mission I guess I
don't know if there is a mission here oh
there is you're right
do you want to do that you want to go to
Blackwater let's do this however
something I got you thought you got
cakes this quick oh yeah sushi can you
not know I have a feeling that this
comes later
like as a story mission oh yeah it says
she's here
i-i can't engage it I say we just go to
black water okay nice and maybe we'll
wait for Lucy how far is she oh she's
right here cool she to us yeah she's
about beer
so yeah let's go uh continue to black
water oh there's a fence there - we can
sell [ __ ] let's go there
that's thieves landing nevermind let's
go there anyway
cool that's for sure that these landings
here we could sell a big somebody wait
someone saying there's a note next to
Bonnie for the stranger thing
oh yeah there's a note on the table
thank you wait no that's not let me pick
it up maybe you can pick it up your
Posse leader oops
Oh is a greet are you just looking for
work talkative thank you yeah we're
trying to get packed up my father wants
to go on a trip avoid the illness plague
in the county he's never run away from
anything in his life
at least that's the way he tells it now
this Mabel please pack all my dresses
and both the guns sweet girl village
idiot would be unkind to miss MacFarlane
yes Amos the wagon of course isn't it's
gone gone where precisely well we don't
know that's what gone means means that
you cannot find okay all right let's not
be a dick it's we're all trying to go on
be a dick this is a beta guy come on
it's beta save that for next week yes
miss MacFarlane you wouldn't you
wouldn't mind trying to find this damn
wagon would you I'll pay you handsomely
we're very short-handed right now you're
[ __ ] psychopath character
you won't get blackout partner I really
want Oh Lucy are you go I did but he did
a backflip when I killed him let's get
out of here someone saw me oh geez what
it like have you been knowing blue or
yellow yellow right oh yeah a lot of um
I'll turn off that Matt was I saying a
lot of like just like absent horses on
the side of the road you know what I
mean just like players who have like oh
geez come and gone I was about to jump
to your horse on accident and then you
just peeled away and she got back on so
what I wasn't so we're looking for that
wagon yeah Johnny asks was that Bonnie
McFarlane it sure was sure was Johnny my
character is only four feet I play as a
dwarf okay
is this fan-made or yes then go down
here where it's near it we gotta come
down here
[ __ ] search the area for a wagon so I
could let cinematic do most of the work
there
where's the wagon I'm still wanted just
so you guys are all aware noted that
cart oh you know we should use it you
use a Eagle Eye I feel like they were
kind of simulating that we should be
using them more often
oh I see it Oh do we have another posse
nippers that you know it's it's NPCs and
um info [ __ ]
that guy's took like six bullets to the
chest yeah sometimes the the NPC's take
like a ton of bullets for sure
nice that's them I'll get the cart it's
like a chariot sweet I know then my
horses follow me
you guys coming got dark real quick oh
I'm going right back into wanted
territory I think I'm fine
oh there I'm going right towards the law
I'm gonna need my posse hold on oh [ __ ]
my stuck in this tree oh no I'm good oh
this can't be good
alright I'll go up ahead Scout whoa so
we've got law NPCs and other players to
worry about that's great that's my fault
I will take full responsibility me the
law right now oh oh [ __ ]
okay who's that who's that it's NPCs I'm
gonna keep writing yeah you're good
sweet how long this is a beta last I the
beta will ease into the actual release I
believe of Red Dead online so in a way
this is essentially read it online this
with beta slice we're almost there couse
we are here how long are we gonna stream
that's a pretty good question I think
we'll probably streaming for another 30
minutes
there you go Bonnie uh yeah that works
for me I've have to go the bathroom no
you don't hear all right cool
that word looks like Arthur from a
distance we got a little bit of gold
some XP with that unlock I'm gonna check
that out rank six ooh military slouch
hat a couple of new horse Mane's where
are you looking in that I just held
actually I um Awards awards or no sorry
story unlocks or sorry rank unlocks
under progress but also when you rank up
I just held options right but they don't
give them to you you have to go actually
buy them and everything
oh right HUD Lucy's characters she's
doing some spins there huh all right
let's go - lets go - thieves landing and
sell some stuff like we all have
it's up to so yeah there's a fence there
yeah yes
because I have two and a half dollars to
my name and my name is Gavin Gavin Lucy
how about mixed business sorry I can't
alright let's ride yes right
yeah this is much more enjoyable when I
mean that'll definitely add fun but I
think that those respawns need to be
like ten seconds longer yeah or let me
just put them at a distance I guess or
like so here's the other thing too is a
GT online they eventually implemented
passive mode so you could like engage
passive mode and no one would be able to
kill you and you but you wouldn't be
able to kill anyone else so I don't know
if that's maybe that's something that
will roll out with this good
have we tried Battle Royale I don't know
if that's in this game yet at least I
was like that leaked a while there's a
leak yeah maybe there's like a mission
type that does something similar yeah
like a PV pygmy roaming by yourself sure
what happened to you here I hit that
post a little bit of a tight Kevin sorry
Gavin can you move your Gavin Lucy
didn't really make the red do this Oh
another one I wasn't in I wasn't or I
don't think I went to thieves Landing
when I owe it so it's it's not complete
which is interesting it's like it's
quite literally like a thieves landing
where there's just a bunch of like
outlaws and shacks it's kind of cool
all right we're here around here oh I
see a small
Dylan that's general store is offense
Dylan that's it right there now that's
the fence oh oh oh that's the exit yeah
there's next time
Dylan asks when will be working xbox
Ultimate Edition owner you should be
able to play right now if you are an
Xbox or sorry if you were an Ultimate
Edition owner that's currently what
what's happening right now anyone who
has the Ultimate Edition can play all
right let's sell I just made like four
bucks yeah I'm probably but a guy sells
some others don't do the same here yeah
I need provide like my cores are low all
right let's go to Blackwater now okay
there's a story mission there let's try
doing that and maybe we'll call it a
stream yeah
someone was asking can you fast travel
so in the Red Dead online menu were
there's free roam and like I want to say
there's like random Posse you can join
it looked like there was um I want to
say like hot areas or like areas you
could free roam and warp to if that
makes sense like it looked like they
were like I want to say five locations
across the whole map that you could you
could kind of spawn into but I don't
think you can do any kind of fast travel
within a certain server server I don't I
don't think that exists well they're
stagecoach or spy that stable upkeep fee
I don't know me so yeah when you back
out and come back in you can choose
where to start and free room and there's
like 13 options yeah that's what I was
referring to and also your camp and
stuff I don't know if you can yeah you
can move your camp I don't know what you
need to do in order to do that though
maybe you can fat well let's go to the
post office and maybe there's like cuz
that you know in the single-player you
go to post offices and that's how you uh
oh oh no so I was me no that was
definitely me my horse does not like me
this guy behind us hopefully don't cause
trouble cuz we ain't looking for it now
Skeeter yeah maybe the post office will
will have a train station
so we're gonna get this mission from
this - yeah I need to do it how was
voice chat there's there's existent
voice chat looks like there was
proximity I would say within the server
yeah it pushed me away because you can
only you can start it where is it this
guy fast travel exists at your camp rank
65 that is world the world's business is
kindness and gentleness and and evil and
and brutality what else is there mister
besides like lust greed and stupidity
mr. Jones a lot of questions coming I'll
answer Michigan get yourself something
to eat
there's fellas need help maybe this
fella can help them maybe they're uh
they're on the run yeah that ain't my
business my businesses
they do hair after that's my business
well they certainly need money money
money for them is this good money for
them is not so good but maybe they could
first go see the sheriff's and see what
works
I reckon for now at least we might as
well try the sheriff black water he
needs help not the fella that arrested
yeah that was the marshal the police
chief he's a decent enough fella for all
we know poor bastard is over running and
he don't want to over children's there's
a couple of other sheriffs they need
help the fella from Valentine he's at
the painted Sky Ranch tumbleweed
sheriff's at the tumbleweed jail and the
Blackwater sheriff he's at Pikes Basin
maybe that'll show us what kind of fella
this is go and pay them all a car that's
what I reckon maybe I guess we will see
me back here after you've seen them
questions xbox beta is still unavailable
yeah I don't know much about Xbox we're
playing on ps4 Pro again Ultimate
Edition owners are able to play today
and if you bought the game at launch and
we're playing it you can play tomorrow
and so forth until Friday where everyone
can play who owns the game come with our
questions there I forgot sway what I
honestly was not really paying attention
what actually just happened something
the opened up here so there's more
missions I guess we just kind of got and
guess so yeah and well let me get on my
horse
really loading
still getting that revolver loading I'm
gonna go see if there's let's go check
to see if you can take a train I really
want to know you're just gonna run
Danu fast my god Jesus so sometime
loading I think I'm still in the
cutscene technically or something
get on yeah just says I'm still loading
it's about to kick me or something I
guess xbox isn't working yeah apparently
maybe the train station isn't in this
town where's isn't our train here maybe
not
oh fast travel so yeah okay cool this is
that each sheriff to continue your work
for horley each sheriff is there one
here that we can visit no I think so
I'm gonna start by a couple things I
might leave well let's do what let's do
one more thing and call it there's a we
can do this sheriff of Blackwater down
here or we can go up want to go up to
the heartlands this one the right side
of the tracks yeah let's go there I
agree
oh well so what's this right here so
we're hoping the sheriff's out old man
Jones if you wish become honorable or
dishonorable it'll help you with a fee
you can just pay to knock it in one
direction I guess yeah did you notice
that there was a deduction from your
account for a stable fee yeah 75 75
cents on how often that happens because
that's kind of why oh my loading is done
maybe I can ride my horse now I can all
right we go hi did you is that your
Waypoint yeah what's right for those of
you who like horse riding well guess
what we're gonna do some more about two
minutes
dan was down him down now [ __ ] I should
have gotten a horse but I'll worry about
that later
is Xbox one live I don't believe it is
apparently there were problems right now
yeah problems yep day it wasn't huge was
it asked Gavin the the update was about
six gigs he was like five something gigs
so it was yeah five point six five
update how are the animals looking are
they as abundant as they were in single
player that's a good question um I'd say
so far yeah I mean it's to be honest
we've been in the desert area and I you
got to go off the road soon down here
just so you know sorry I like it so no I
guess I'm trying to say is that like I
haven't played much of the game in the
desert so it's hard for me to kind of
gauge but we are going up north so maybe
we can have a better a better idea but I
would say that it's been okay I can't
really say it's been significantly worse
I mean I guess I'm seeing a lot of birds
some foxes but again that was the desert
so you're not gonna see like D as much
dear maybe we'll see more here this is
the longest we've stayed in a posse yeah
it's a good point you know what I become
I've been kind of noticing is I feel
like we'll we'll be okay with three I
feel like when we started doing like
four was when people started dropping
out yeah but that being said it has the
connection or connectivity has not been
great even we've been getting
disconnected or people been talking
someone's ambushing us right now there's
like a gang behind us oh they're wolves
sorry there's your answer there
there are some wolves put your dogs on a
leash there we go let's skin them
skinnies get some money like that's
something you really gotta start doing
is like if you're playing by yourself
like me you know find a way to make
money and that's that's gonna be the
real question in this game is how do you
make money yeah effectively and
efficiently the skinning animations are
still as grotesque as ever how do you
unlock beta we have been answering this
a lot so if you have the ultimate
edition of Red Dead online or Red Dead
Redemption - you can play it now if you
don't and you bought the game at launch
you can play it tomorrow and I think
then there's another date associated
with people who own the game but by
Friday if you own Red Dead Redemption -
you play read that online beta did they
say how long the beta is gonna last I
don't believe so at least it's not
coming to my mind right now
two ferns eleven outs can you eat the
horse you know that's a good question I
don't think so can you get wild horses
yeah probably you have a lasso and there
are stables yeah I'd be surprised if you
can can you pan for gold in the game I
don't think you can do that in the
single-player so I doubt it
can we eat human I don't think so
panning for gold have you watched the
ballot of Buster scrubs yet yeah I did
everyone did a Tom Waits episode that
was my favorite one as good what does
money buy you in the online game it
cosmetics and weapons and stuff pretty
much same stuff but it's but the only
unfortunate thing is that they're locked
behind your ring so you need to be like
and this was similar to GTA online you
need to be a certain rank in order to
unlock it and then you buy it with the
currency and game or it sounds like you
can pay real world money for gold and
gold is represented there in the top
right
seventy seventeen cents I haven't gold
worth here I don't know I don't know how
much gold is but it would be present
sweet oh this is when you do the first
mission for mr. space Strauss
all right so let's engage it oh you're
right so why the black borders I don't
know you're talking about uh start
mission is it Battle Royale no can you
play as a preacher you probably role
play as a preacher if you want it you
can lasso your friends as we saw yeah
you can definitely lasso your friends
and it can get a little annoying but
you're able to break free which is
interesting you just have to like tap or
mash the button in order to do so so
this is similar to like the one of the
first ones we did right yeah like I
joined purchases so you can buy stuff
here huh this is very very much like GTL
our visions here we go I don't anything
for my horse Oh where'd you see
provisions on your purchases how much
time I single-player story money weapons
horses in what their story money weapons
horses is only in story question I don't
know I don't know that one who are you
who are you I'm Rob this is Mike why I
don't know God how I don't know Bob
process more support and funding will
you go for me wait what go that's
radical property for some goddamn tea
hey nobody knows who took your stuff
mister I seem like some kind of liar is
that why you won't help me no but listen
give me Bob crawfish and his closest
associates by any means necessary
[Laughter]
sir kill no bottom we're helping the
sheriff around painted sky for guy named
Bob prophet bring them to me just down
from four great station you can put
people in the back of your horse we
found that out yeah you can definitely
have your horse fleet yeah persons still
tied to it yeah also jump to other
people's horses you ride on the back
yeah some options for sure so what are
we doing finding as hot as a nearby er
no
take out his hired guns subdue crawfish
and his boys so he's got to stay alive
we're gonna lasso him and interesting
and his associates yeah oh sweet works
so it's killing yeah I don't know why
it's not I'm maybe I'm seven bad luck
I'm not paying attention our weapon
degradation is their weapon degradation
multiplayer oh I'll have to check in a
second yes there is oh this is where you
do the gold bar money glitch yeah there
is degradation Wow
yeah like if there's anything I've been
noticing is that oh my god there's
ending of I know so you you like if
you're if you're gonna go up against
actual people in this game there are a
lot of steps you need to take in order
to prep you know what I mean like you
get tonics you do you clean your weapons
dead eyes helpful Deadeye
like there's a lot there's a lot to like
any kind of action worst chasing down a
last of them yeah like one each oh wait
why did we get our mouse on my horse
where you really yeah it's [ __ ]
after boys
my last weapon shoot them on exit
all right so lasso it up huh shooting at
us - its oh man they're spreading out
I'll go I'll go far left all right I
think someone's going right I'm gonna I
got this guy right here
oh man did they all go right to shake I
I guess I think they're gonna merge
maybe again I'm here I'm here
alright I'm gonna go after this guy all
right I got him
[Music]
got one someone killed him I don't know
maybe I did but it didn't look like it
yeah I guess we'll do the checkpoint oh
[Music]
yeah the missions are like fun when
they're fun and it's fun riding with our
people it's just it gets the respawn
time on like when you're fighting PvP
you respawn almost immediately and not
and then you just start getting into
this like loop you know it's a you spawn
like not that far away so if you can get
there is wildlife and online someone
asks again
how does Dead Eye work against real
players well there's like three types of
dead I they that are separated into
cards so you you put a car down only one
at a time and they can be different
things so like I have one that does the
dead I like classic tag Oh someone
protecting the one and shoot them and
then there's also a damage boost or a
health boost which are different
someone's around there dude that was me
then also look what I'll get this guy on
the right right here I'm right next to
you you go left go left yeah wait wait
wait to leaves uh out of the water right
he's out I got one
where's Lucy I'm not gonna have room for
this last guy oh no he just riding
around anyway
Lucy all right
everybody got there's one yeah Lucy's
daughters
do I need ps+ to play online yeah you
probably do or yeah you do take them to
the tracks at four rigs what are we
gonna do these guys
it really goes to show how much like the
old Red Dead one map is not as good you
know I mean like this is far more like
enjoyable to look at oh hey oh that's
him we're gonna play chicken with him
sorry
let's hope so well like red dead
this makes me want to play single-player
but this is fun when it's working earth
when it's not go to the thief yeah you
got a drop him right on the tracks oh I
did it this guy's
Oh guys cool Rob you where's my property
I don't rightly know what you're talking
about you my fine collection gone
missing getting crushed by a train gone
my collection of photographs of fairies
oh here won't you go kill my sister
Gotha leave them on the tracks
you could worm your way out of there
right
Oh interesting warrior harambe just
agreed with us
oh sure we want to watch this hell yeah
this is one hell of a way to close the
stream I was like that oh it's coming
over the bridge
someone ping sounds like she'll be
coming around the mountain when she
comes
she'll be coming this is really fun
oh my god dismemberment
living that dismemberment life that was
good ending yeah Lucy's character does
need a bath yeah Lucy yeah this is
character smells that was a good like
fatality ending okay
fatality all right well let's wrap this
up see where it spits us out and then
we'll close it
that's why yawn
and I miss the Red Dead one loading
animation what was that one well it's
the same but like you saw the bullets
all like oh yeah get shot out sweet
alright yeah what kind of I want see
what kind of a experience we got for
that yeah see my honors oh my god that
brought my honor way down oh sure dude
look at mine that's what that's that's
interesting like for a second I was I
was like why are we doing this but
that's what it was oh yeah so if that's
press left and go-to player you can see
all of our reputations if you click on
someone report or view profile
oh no sorry that's PlayStation is it
report oh that's to report someone I saw
someone oh here we go
so our Posse was dishonorable where are
you going Oh to posses click on you and
then view Posse hovering over it got it
err click on me and then view Posse I
think that brought all of us down yeah
all right well cool um yeah yeah I'll
keep going I said a rival posse started
mission boner it's the posse from before
that's gonna do it look like Lucy was on
her cell phone oh that's a camera oh
yeah posse and you're cool thanks for
joining every yeah thanks for watching
everyone if you have all three edition
you can go play this if you haven't
already if you played Red Dead
Redemption - on launch day October 26th
at all or if the game registers you have
having played you can play the ultimate
edition tomorrow morning I don't know
the exact time it might be the same
thing like 5 7:30 Eastern 8:30 Eastern
and then it's gonna be like rolling out
to everybody over the next few days if
you played between the 26 and the 29th
and then I think people in the chat were
saying and I believe this is true
although don't call me and I believe the
beta will just go right into the actual
launch of rent
this might as well be read that online
it is so I don't know pretty fun it
would kind of got frustrating with how
quick those respawns were when we were
fighting another posse yeah you kind of
you kind of get thrown into a vicious
loop which was frustrating yeah but it
was fun when it works like playing with
you guys it was fun it was fun when it
worked and it was also cool when it
wasn't kicking anyone or disconnecting
yeah that it got more stable as time
went on but at first and we had like
five four people in the posse it was
just kicking with someone like every
five minutes yeah but I mean the last
stretch there the last hour I want to
say it was actually pretty pretty cool
yeah worked out so yeah we covered when
you could play this so essentially by
Friday everyone should be able to play
the online um and yeah so far so cool
for more read down online coverage stay
tuned we'll probably be doing maybe some
guy D stuff or just like a rundown on
like what you can expect from this where
you should be doing maybe in a couple
weeks how to make some money because I'd
like to know that had how to get the
bang for your buck you know oh cool
thanks Mike yeah thank you guys all so
much for watching and have a great rest
of the week
take care so yes outro